I was later my grandfather was expecting
and by being born
I broke the line back to the Ancient
Ones keisha Castle Hughes was the
youngest Best Actress nominee at the
2004 Oscars for Whale Rider what do you
remember about that night it's some weed
the things that you remember I remember
being really hungry I remember always
kinda like sneak little craisins like in
between shots sitting down with ET
Keisha talks about how much her life has
changed especially when she became a
mother at 17 what was the biggest
challenge of being a teen mom um I don't
know I mean it was obviously it's
challenging becoming a mom at any point
you know right but I was really lucky
I'd like incredible family support
around me my family have always been
very close and I've come from a really
big family as well and so the whole
thing was always it was just kind of
like one more and thus a big tribe that
we already had and so it's been it's
been a wild ride I mean my little girls
like a little person now and so was she
nine she's nine yeah so it's pretty wild
like she's got her own whole opinions
and ideas it's really exciting and you
know I think too like in this line of
work it gives you a lot of perspective
I think the best advice I ever got from
my mom was like no matter no matter what
happens there will be a period and your
your life and her life where no matter
you're not cold and you just have to be
okay with me you know and it said it's
over because I'm like hang in like I'm
cool mom you know she's like oh my god I
did that to my mom I feel awful about it
so I think Kisha has always been a
standout in her roles from the Nativity
story to Game of Thrones and now Cameron
Crowe's new Showtime series roadies is
yeah roadies is a show about a bunch of
roadies who after a big American rock
band created by Cameron Crowe who I
think is the most qualified person to be
telling the story given his own history
it's a similar world to almost famous
just from like a different perspective
and sit and the now your mom was a
roadie she was she wasn't roadie which
was just so bizarre what are the chips I
know she's really young and so this is
super exciting as well for her what is
your mom tell you about her time on the
road I mean she had a blast it's so
funny she's kind of like quite secretive
about a lot of his stories she likes to
keep them to herself it was pretty her
being a mom I guess but she but she's
really excited she's she's been a mess
of Cameron Crowe Fame for a very long
time
she's freaking out yes you're freaking
out and it's really nice because I mean
I've been doing this for a pretty long
time mm-hmm she's always been very proud
of me